la campagne des élections municipales
lancé à guyancourt après à une liste
participative qui s'est lancé dans la
campagne en mars une deuxième
candidature déclarée c'est la vôtre
rodolphe barry bonds soir bonsoir
alors vous êtes candidat sans étiquette
pour ces élections municipales vous
mènerez la liste ensemble agissons pour
guyancourt et vous habitez la ville
alors depuis moins de deux ans voilà
deux ans environ vous êtes un ancien élu
de voisins-le-bretonneux vous avez été
maire adjoint jusqu'en 2014 pourquoi
vous lancer à guyancourt
pourquoi guyancourt parce que d'abord
j'y suis donc pourquoi pas ça parce
qu'on a été élu dans une autre commune
qu'on ne peut pas se présenter dans une
autre commune les saf la porte est aussi
certaine expérience tout à fait en fait
on peut le voir de manière positive à
dire que j'ai une certaine expérience
donc aujourd'hui je mettre l'expérience
que j'ai au profit d'étudiants courtois
et le fait d'habiter depuis moins de
deux ans dans cette ville est ce que
c'est suffisant finalement pour bien
connaître la ville bien connaître les
dossiers de cette ville de guyancourt
alors dû en cours a déjà je suis un
enfant de saint quentin en yvelines donc
je suis jeu j'y vis j'y travaille je
travaille à exactement à 50 mètres de la
limite de guyancourt
je fais mes courses donc c'est une ville
que je connais je participe depuis deux
ans à tous les conseils municipaux
d'accord donc je m'intéresse à ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui aujourd'hui a dit
encore oui alors à la tête de
municipalités actuellement il ya
françois morton maire divers gauche de
guyancourt qui a été élu en mai suite à
la démission de marie christine le
tarnec pour raisons de santé
l'ancien maire qui avait elle même
succédé à françois de ligne est
démissionnaire en 2016 dire qu'il ya eu
trois maires sur le même mandat de
cuillé 2014
quel est le regard que vous portez sur
l'équipe actuelle en place alors le
regard déjà que je les connais pas moi
titre à titre personnel j'en connais
quelques-uns forcément puisque j'étais
j'ai été élu donc j'en connais
quelques-uns c'est un peu perturbant
parce que c'est vrai que c'est un peu
atypique d'avoir trois maires en un
mandat ça fait trente et un ans qui sont
plus de 31 ans même qu'ils sont qui sont
aux affaires sans sans partage de
pouvoir depuis 2000 14 ans n'a eu
monsieur de linux est présente et qui a
priori
n'a pas n'a pas informé la population
qui ne ferait pas son mandat de madame
le tarnec et puis maintenant monsieur
morton atypiques comme plus 30 ans qui
est que c'est peu ou prou la même équipe
en place ça veut dire que les électeurs
redonne aussi leur confiance à chaque
mandat sans doute mais à l'époque n'est
peut-être pas d'autres d'autres
alternatives s'est recalé de liste et
aujourd'hui on est on part sur puce de
plus de deux listes trois voire quatre
listes donc ça permettra ou bien pour
toi d'avoir une autre alternative
et nous notre objectif s'est donné un
nouveau souffle on parle effectivement
de 4 lié je parlais tout à l'heure de
cette liste participative votre
candidature le maire actuel françois
menton qui pourrait se représenter ou
parle également d'une liste la
république en marche mais voilà ce n'est
pas encore officiel pour vous quelles
sont les priorités
justement pour cette ville de guyancourt
quels sont les dossiers phares à traiter
à guyancourt
alors on a on a un dossier qui est assez
important que c'est à l'aise par exemple
le projette alex c'est aussi redonner m
but en cours au coeur de au coeur de
saint quentin en yvelines
c'est toi ils ont réussi aujourd'hui à
se fâcher avec avec avec la communauté
d'agglomération il faut pas oublier que
la communauté d'agglomération
aujourd'hui gère à la compétence sauf 50
% de ce qui se passe sur toutes les
communes donc aujourd'hui vous prenez
thales par exemple qui est un gros
projets sont aujourd'hui en cours
le ville de billancourt n'a plus la
compétence comme s'ils ont réussi à se
fâcher avec tout le monde et à faire en
sorte que le préfet donne cette
compétence a loupé aps mais jean michel
fourgous le présente saint quentin en
yvelines avait quand même ouvert à la
ville de guyancourt puisqu'une vice
président saleh a été accordée à
marie-christine le tarnec
j'ai envie de vous dire posez leur la
question quand madame le tarnec a fait
son discours lors des voeux elle a
expliqué que ça se passait pas bien avec
la communauté des données ration quand
monsieur morton a fait son discours lors
de son élection il a également eu des
mots contre la communauté
d'agglomération que j'aimerais qu'à
l'élite posez leur la question
alors quand vous étiez maire adjoint
voisins le bretonneux vous étiez dans
une majorité de droite celle d'alexis
biette est ce que votre liste alors je
le disais s'il sans étiquette ça veut
dire que
on n'aura pas cette sensibilité de
droite sait plus se faire appel à
différentes sensibilités politiques
- pour être transparents je suis
centriste donc l'objectif c'est de
d'ouvrir 7 7 7 listes au plus grand
nombre
que ce soit à droite ou gauche on est
sur une élection locale une légende une
commune ya pas exactement si kate sont
moins les projets qui comptent
exactement à l'échelle d'une
municipalité on est on est vraiment sûr
sur du projet local quand on va débattre
sur une route c'est pas la route de
droite ou la route de gauche c'est la
route de tout le monde
donc l'objectif c'est d'avoir une vie
une vie ce qui est vraiment très très
large une liste citoyenne
mais justement pour votre liste est ce
que vous avez tous vos colistiers vous
êtes encore à la recherche de votre
équipe on est menés aux démarches et une
petite j'ai un petit noyau autour de moi
on est on est presque une trentaine
aujourd'hui voilà à travailler ça ne pas
dire toutes ces personnes à sion sur la
liste mais aujourd'hui il ya un noyau
qui est qui et qui est qui et qui est
dans la dynamique de ce projet une
dernière minute il nous reste une
dernière minute vous parlais tout à
l'heure des priorités j'avais lu dans un
entretien au nouvel de versailles qui
est aussi une fibre écologiste chez vous
il ya des projets sur sur le côté
écologique vous les mettez titre
personnel je juge une fibre écologique
assez pro après assez prononcé virons
sur sur des basiques à guyancourt
pourquoi pas mettre le bio dans toutes
les écoles vient ça se fait dans
d'autres communes ça se fait pas à
guyancourt
pourquoi pas réduire l'empreinte carbone
peuvent surtout travailler là dessus
quand je vois qu'au dernier conseil
municipal sur le dob
on vous explique que la municipalité à
changer les ampoules de la mairie par
des ampoules led
je pense qu'il ya d'autres projets sur
la partie développement durable
écologique pour du en cours des
élections municipales qui sont
programmés en 2020 pas de date de date
exacte encore arrêtée à guyancourt je
disais tout à l'heure
outre la liste participative décident
ensemble à guyancourt le maire de la
majorité actuelle françois morton
devrait également se représenter une
liste la république en marche est
également en projet et vous c'est sûr
rodolphe barrez vous conduirez la liste
sans étiquette ensemble agissons pour
but en cours merci tout à fait d'être
passé sur ce plateau merci de votre
accueil